à compter d'aujourd'hui 1er juillet
votre billet de métro d'autobus à
Montréal passe de 3 dollars 50 à 3
dollars 75 et devient le billet de
transport en commun le plus cher au
Canada selon les risques institut de
recherche et d'information
socio-économiques en comparaison à des
villes comme Toronto ou le billet
unitaire coûte 3 dollars 35 ou Vancouver
à 3 dollars 15 c'est sûr que tout
augmente écoute la vie devient très dure
je connais beaucoup de gens pour qui ça
touche surtout ceux qui habitent pas à
Montréal et qui doivent acheter les
postes AB ou ABC une réplique tout taxé
autre chose que le transport parce que
nous on
se passe pour prendre des transports
pour éviter le surplus de pollution avec
un manque à gagner de 500 millions de
dollars cette année l'autorité régionale
de transport métropolitain dit avoir été
contrainte d'augmenter de 3% le prix de
ces titres de transport dans le Grand
Montréal dans la région ici les
les gens qui achètent des titres
contribuent à 30% du financement des
services ce qui est pas toujours la même
situation un peu partout dans le monde
pour des personnes à faible revenu c'est
une hausse de prix qui ne passe pas
je trouve c'est plus difficile d'acheter
des passeurs j'ajoute plus des coups de
billets à ce moment-là
beaucoup moins cher mais je veux dire
que je le prends moins aussi souvent que
avant aussi alors que certains comme
Robert Roussel rêve d'un transport
gratuit ou adapté à leur moyen la Ville
de Montréal offre la gratuité au
montréalais de 65 ans et plus la
gratuité des aînés ça va coûter à terme
40 millions pour l'agglomération de
Montréal c'est une mesure sociale
justement pour faire face à l'inflation
de population très vulnérable les aînés
ont des revenus fixes une mesure à
l'image des besoins en mobilité face à
la voiture solo ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal